would it surprise you if the very people
who purport to be all about the
environment and green technologies and
they love the Earth but you evil
Republicans hate it because somehow you
care about capitalism or something like
that would it surprise you if they were
actually the ones doing the most damage
to the environment and not only doing
the most damage to the environment but
doing the most damage to the people
who live on this Earth speaking of that
the EU Parliament has just voted to ban
petrol car sales by 2035 how they're
going to replace them no idea but here's
uh some applauding after the vote vote
is closed
and it is adopted and thereby the first
reading of parliament is closed thank
you
[Applause]
very exciting guys no more petrol cars
in the EU by 2035 we don't know how
we're gonna you know keep people on the
roads or if any of this makes sense but
we just do things that sort of sound
right we'll deal with the consequences
later
[Music]
foreign